okay good afternoon i'm assistant
sheriff brett zimmerman and i'm here to
brief you on additional details as we
know them today about the officer
involved shooting that occurred on
monday
march 1st 2021. this is ois number three
for 2021
non-fatal number two at the same time
last year we were at ois number three
and non-fatal number three the date time
and type of call
was march 1st 2021 at 11 58 a.m
and it was an attempt suicide the
location of the ois
was lamb boulevard and alto avenue
in a desert lot las vegas nevada 89115
which is in the northeast area command
and you can see
see the scene on to the left
our involved officer was officer vidal
contreras
first name is spelled v-i-d-a-l last
name contreras c-o-n
t-r-e-r-a-s he's 30 years old and has
been with the lvmpd
since 2017. in this incident officer
contreras was armed with a staccato
and i'll spell that s-t-a-c-c-a-t-o
model p-duo duo
nine-millimeter handgun equipped with an
optic and a tactical light
the investigation revealed he fired two
rounds
officer contreras is assigned to the
community policing division
at the northeast area command our
suspect
is a seth greenstone he's a 31 year old
native american male
adult 5 feet 11 and weighs 235 pounds
he's pictured to my left his weapon
was a box cutter
mr greenstone's charges assault on a
public officer with a deadly weapon
and resisting a public officer with a
deadly weapon
the details of the ois on monday march
1st 2021 at approximately 11 58 a.m
lvmp dispatch center received an
anonymous call
about a man who was at the corner of
cecile avenue and lamb boulevard
armed with a knife and who had blood on
his neck
the caller went on to say that the male
was acting erratically
and might be trying to hurt himself or
someone else
through our follow-up investigation we
have determined the anonymous
the anonymous caller was in fact seth
greenstone calling about himself
based on this information the call taker
categorized what we call
a star protocol to refresh everyone's
memory
in regards to our department policy the
star protocol stands for
supervisor tactic for armed subject
response
and the following criteria must be met
to meet this star protocol
one there is a credible information that
the subject with
that there is a subject armed with a
firearm or other dangerous weapon
it can't be simulated or unseen and
using it in a manner that can cause
death
or serious bodily injury two the subject
is acting in a threatening manner
with the weapon and three this will not
include
any of our open carry individuals
or subjects with pocket knives when
carrying the weapon
is the sole justification for the call
a sergeant and several officers were
dispatched to the call
while enroute to the location that
sergeant and one of the officers
conducted a pedestrian stop on a mail
matching the description of mr
greenstone
near lamb boulevard and cartier
boulevard
cartier avenue the sergeant updated the
pedestrian stop was not related
officer contreras drove northbound
passing those units
and continued to look for the individual
near lamb boulevard
and alto avenue officer contreras
spotted mr greenstone
walking out of a vacant lot
officer contreras advised dispatch of
his location
and reported that mr greenstone was
armed with a knife
officer contreras exited his patrol
vehicle and ordered mr greenstone to
drop the knife
mr green stone ignored those commands
and advanced towards officer contreras
while holding the knife in his left hand
officer contreras fired his duty weapon
at mr greenstone striking him mr
greenstone
fell to the ground and was taken into
custody by arriving officers
medical was immediately requested and mr
greenstone
was transported to umc trauma where he
is currently listed in stable condition
our follow-up investigation revealed
that mr greenstone's place of employment
is near the location of the
officer-involved shooting
on that day of the ois mr greenstone had
been at work
but he left after borrowing a box cutter
from one of his co-workers at this time
i will now show you the body worn camera
footage
of the ois well i'm sorry i'm going to
play the nine i'm sorry
at this time i'll first play the 911
call then we'll show the body worn
camera
1 2 021
11 56 and 18
seconds
before fan from land to china
yeah before fame okay so we're on land
ready
on the northbound or the southbound side
then northbound
okay so you're northbound lanes before
cheyenne
yeah yeah in the desert area
what's going on there's a guy with a
knife what is he getting
his name i don't know he's actually
crazy
yeah where's the desert area
right after are you just past the seal
um i think it's before
you don't know how close it is just to
know
how long did you see him he's out there
right now
okay do you see him from where you are
no i just go by him
okay so you drove him what two minutes
ago yeah
okay so you think it's before to feel
yeah i think he's trying to
hurt himself by somebody okay do you
know if he's near also
you know i don't even
[Music]
did you see the knife yeah okay
okay and here's a body worn camera from
officer contreras
[Music]
all right
okay this concludes the briefing i'll
take any questions if anybody has any
yes ma'am
that's what it looks like to us he did
have injuries from the
that look like we're self-inflicted so
yes he
i i don't know the extent of those
injuries but he did have blood on
himself and it was caused by that box
cutter and then do you feel like he
called police
to maybe have officers then shoot him
was it
any time that i mean if
i had to guess you know that could be
but
uh you know i i don't really know know
his mindset but
he did call on himself obviously
has the officer who was involved has
even involved in any
previous police shooting no this is his
first ois
okay thank you for coming